[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend und
Willkommen zu 20 Minuten Nachrichten im
Sport erfahren Sie von Norbert Lehmann
was im Fußball passiert ist
und in den USA liefern sich Demokraten
und Republikaner einige enge Rennen bei
den Kongresswahlen
Zitterpartie in den USA nach den
wichtigen Zwischenwahlen stehen einige
Ergebnisse nach aus ein Durchmarsch der
Republikaner ist aber nicht zu erkennen
höhere Steuern für Spitzenverdiener die
sogenannten Wirtschaftsweisen fordern in
der Energiekrise eine Kurskorrektur vom
Finanzminister aber der lehnt das ab
und Rückzug aus Restaurant der russische
Verteidigungsminister kündigt an die
Truppen aus Teilen der Region im Süden
der Ukraine abzuziehen
die Republikaner hatten mit einem großen
Erfolg bei den Kongresswahlen in den USA
gerechnet aber der ist ausgeblieben für
die Demokraten läuft es besser als in
den Umfragen vorausgesagt allerdings
könnten alle Ergebnisse für Senat und
Repräsentantenhaus möglicherweise erst
Anfang Dezember feststehen
gewählt wurden alle Abgeordneten im
Repräsentantenhaus im Senat ging es um
gut ein Drittel der Sitze nach den
jüngsten Zahlen liegen die Republikaner
im Repräsentantenhaus vorn bei noch 45
offenen sitzen in der zweiten Kammer
sieht es noch knapper aus mit den jetzt
neu gewählten Senatorinnen und Senatoren
kommen die Republikaner auf 49 die
Demokraten auf 48 Sitze aus Washington
Benjamin Daniel
die Ruhe vor diesem deiner in Virginia
trügerisch denn das Rennen um den
Kongress ist noch lange nicht gelaufen
und so verfolgen die Gäste drinnen
gespannt die neuesten Zahlen
ich befürchte die Politik wird zum
Stillstand kommen die Republikaner
werden wohl das Haus knapp gewinnen und
die Demokraten wohl den Senat das würde
alles im Kongress verlangsamen
ich bin erleichtert dass die Faschisten
nicht mehr Gewinne eingefahren haben
vor der Nacht sah es vielerort so aus
lange Schlangen um die Wahllokale im
ganzen Land noch nie haben so viele
Amerikaner bei Kongresswahlen abgestimmt
ohne nennenswerte Zwischenfälle und auch
wenn noch vieles offen ist erklären die
Republikaner bereits
es ist klar dass wir das Haus
zurückerobern
in Florida entscheiden die Republikaner
die Wahlen deutlich für sich unter
anderem kann Ron Disentis seinen
gouverneurs-posten behaupten dieser
klare Sieg könnte ihn bei einer
möglichen Präsidentschaftskandidatur
beflügeln
wir wurden attackiert wir haben
einstecken müssen wir mussten Stürmer
aushalten aber wir haben uns all dem
entgegengestellt wir haben uns dadurch
gebracht und wir hatten den Mut
anzuführen
im umkämpften Pennsylvania hingegen
gewinnt der Demokrat John vetterman
seine Rennen und verkündet ich bin stolz
dass wir mit den richtigen Themen
angetreten sind wir werden das Recht auf
abtreibungs schützen
[Musik]
den Mindestlohn erhöhen
und wir werden für unsere Demokratie
einstehen wer am Ende tatsächlich die
Mehrheiten hinter diesen Mauern inne
haben wird ist bisher nicht entschieden
noch zur Stunde laufen die Zählungen
gehen wir direkt zu unseren
Korrespondenten vor Ort und zuerst zu
ihnen Johannes Hanau sie sind in
Pennsylvania wo sich der Kandidat der
Demokraten gegen den der Republikaner
durchsetzen konnte der ja von Trump
unterstützt wurde was war
ausschlaggebend für den Sieg
desdemokraten
also wenn man es kurz machen will dann
waren die Wählerinnen und Wähler hier in
Prinz pencilvania den Trump schon
Extremismus Leid beide republikanischen
Kandidaten für den Senat und für den
Gouverneurs für das Gouverneursamt waren
Kandidaten von Trumps Gnaden Mac mit
Austria den Senat ein 500 Millionen
Dollar schwerer Fernseh ist da und
herzirurg hatte sich noch mal schnell
gewandelt vom Abtreibungsbefürworter zum
Abtreibungsgegner um Trumps
Unterstützung zu bekommen und
dagmastriano ist einer der
extremistischsten Vertreter der Theorie
das Donald Trump die war gestohlen
worden ist die Demokraten hier haben
sich ganz eindeutig als
Abtreibungsbefürworter und Verteidiger
der Demokratie etabliert und nach ersten
Analysen sieht es so aus dass sie damit
vor allen Dingen Frauen und junge Wähler
mobilisieren konnten und ganz zum
Schluss haben auch noch mal Präsident
beiden und Präsident Ex-Präsident Obama
hier in den Wahlkampf eingegriffen haben
gesagt ja wir verstehen Wirtschaft und
Inflation das sind große Themen die aber
es gibt ein Thema das überall in anderen
steht und das ist die Verteidigung der
amerikanischen Demokratie die steht hier
auf dem Spiel das scheint hier
angekommen zu sein die Strategie ist
aufgegangen gehen wir mal Washington zu
MRT Wissen Emma die Republikaner sind
also weniger erfolgreich als gedacht bei
den Kongresswahlen noch aber sind ja
nicht alle Ergebnisse da wie ist denn
ihre Zwischenbilanz
ja ich glaube es ist schon klar dass aus
der angeblichen roten Wella am Ende ein
Plätschern geworden ist und das hat eben
mit den beiden genannten Themen zu tun
Abtreibung aber auch die Angst vor dem
Extremismus der trumpisten hier und das
dürfte auch innerhalb der
republikanischen Partei massiv für
Streit Sorgen denn die Partei muss
überlegen ob sie sich weiter mit
Kandidaten zusammentut und sehen lässt
die eben trampismus folgen die
möglicherweise auch Donald Trump als
Unterstützer haben denn das könnte ihre
Wahlchancen mildern wir wissen das im
Senat die Chancen für die Demokraten
sehr gut sind tatsächlich am Ende die
Mehrheit zu behalten möglicherweise auch
noch eine Stimme draufzulegen und im
Repräsentantenhaus gibt es historisch
gesehen normalerweise immer im
Durchschnitt 30 Mandate mehr für die
Oppositionspartei bei einer zwischenwahl
in der ersten Amtszeit eines Präsidenten
da liegen die Republikaner weiter hinter
zurück vielleicht ist es einstellig die
Demokraten könnten das
Repräsentantenhaus sogar noch gewinnen
also am Ende wenn es ein Referendum über
Joe auch war das ganze dann ist das für
die re:publikaner krachend daneben
gegangen danke für diese Einordnung
in den USA
und die Ergebnisse der Zwischenwahlen in
den USA sind auch gleich Thema an einem
zdf-spezial direkt im Anschluss an
dieser Sendung außerdem können Sie sich
über die aktuellen Entwicklungen
jederzeit in unserem Live-Blog
informieren auf ZDF heute und in unserer
App
nach Deutschland heute haben die fünf
Wirtschaftsweisen ihr Jahresgutachten an
Bundeskanzler Scholz überreicht
für dieses Jahr rechnen Sie mit einem
Wachstum von 1,7 Prozent und für das
Jahr 2023 mit einem Minus von
0,2%. einer milden Rezession also den
Inflationsrate dürfte 2023
durchschnittlich bei 7,4% liegen um den
Start zu entlasten empfiehlt das Gremium
zeitlich befristet einen höheren
Spitzensteuersatz oder ein energiesoli
Frank Buchwald
viel zu lesen für den Kanzler 400 Seiten
Jahresgutachten der Ausblick jedoch
ziemlich trübe wir sind als Land
ärmer geworden durch diese Krise
irgendjemand muss das zahlen das können
nicht einfach nur unsere Kinder sein
auch deshalb empfehlen die
Sachverständigen einen höheren
Spitzensteuersatz oder einen energiesoli
für hohe Einkommen zusätzlich raten Sie
den Abbau der kalten Progression
aufzuschieben die kalte Progression zu
verschieben hat eben auch Effekte schon
in der einkommensmitte die nach oben
halt weiter zunehmen aber sowas wie ein
Energie Soli eine Erhöhung des
Spitzensteuersatzes wir haben all das
nicht quantifiziert wir haben nicht
gesagt wie viel muss man dagegen
finanzieren aber in diese Richtung zu
gehen erschien uns wichtig auch für die
Sozialdemokraten klingt das durchaus
verlockend
da ist ganz offenkundig dass der
Haushalt vieles nicht hergibt was wir
uns vorgenommen haben und deswegen
müssen wir meiner Auffassung nach auch
eben die sehr hohen Einkommen die
wirklich sehr sehr hohen Einkommen und
die sehr hohen Vermögen stärker belasten
der Finanzminister jedoch weist solche
Vorschläge entschieden zurück die
Bundesregierung beabsichtigt keine
Steuern zu erhöhen die Bundesregierung
hält daran fest dass wir in dieser
Situation eher entlasten müssen die
Union sieht das ganz ähnlich der
Spitzensteuersatz greift schon bei etwa
2000 Euro und die Menschen noch mehr zu
belasten ist keine Lösung wir müssen an
die Ursachen ran und Ursache der hohen
Energiepreise ist es wir zu wenig
Energie haben deshalb raten die Experten
die Atomkraftwerke länger laufen zu
lassen auch über April nächsten Jahres
hinaus neuer zündstoffwohl für die
Koalition
das Kindergeld wird erhöht zum ersten
Januar soll es für jedes Kind 250 Euro
im Monat geben darauf einigten sich die
ampelfraktion zudem legte die Koalition
ihren Streit bei über die klimaabgabe
für Wohngebäude so müssen Mieterinnen
und Mieter ab Januar den CO2-Preis beim
Heizen nicht mehr alleine tragen auch
Vermieterinnen und Vermieter sollen sich
daran beteiligen geplant ist ein
Stufenmodell
und noch eine Entscheidung wurde im
Kabinett getroffen sie hat eine
wirtschaftspolitische Bedeutung denn
nachdem die Bundesregierung dafür
kritisiert wurde dass sie China erlaubt
in den Hamburger Hafen zu investieren
hat die Regierung jetzt in zwei Fällen
chinesischen Firmen untersagt bei
deutschen Hightech-Unternehmen
einzusteigen bei einem der beiden
handelt es sich um elmos einem
Dortmunder Chip-Hersteller mehr von
Diana zimmermann
ganz einer Meinung sind hier zwei wenn
es um gesunde Distanz zu China geht dem
Bundeswirtschaftsminister aber gelang es
heute wohl auch ohne Mühe den Kanzler
und das restliche Kabinett zu überzeugen
deutsche Halbleiter und chip-unternehmen
dürfen nicht mal teilweise an
chinesische Investoren gehen so wurde
entschieden vor dem Kanzleramt
bestätigte Harbeck später das Kabinett
habe gleich zwei investitionsverbote
ausgesprochen beide sind damit begründet
dass die Sicherheit der Ordnung in
Deutschland gewahrt und geschützt werden
muss und kritische Produktionsbereiche
einer besonderen Schutz Notwendigkeit
unterliegen bei den betroffenen Firmen
handelt es sich um die bayerische
halbleiterfirma ers und die
chipfertigung des Dortmunder
Unternehmens elmos 225 Arbeitsplätze
seien gefährdet klagt elmos aber auch
von der Opposition gibt es keine
Unterstützung wir müssen jetzt wirklich
lernen die Fehler die wir in einer
Abhängigkeit zu Russland im Bereich
gemacht haben nicht noch einmal zu
wiederholen und natürlich sind diese
Arbeitsplätze wichtig aber wir müssen
lernen geopolitisch zu denken
das ist der Anspruch an ganz Europa und
endlich auch an Deutschland nach
Jahrzehnten in den diverse deutsche
Bundesregierungen chinesischen
Investoren den roten Teppich ausrollten
und über jede deutsche firmenöffnung in
China jubelten soll nun die Abhängigkeit
von China reduziert werden spät
vielleicht zu spät
immer höhere Preise deshalb legten in
zwei europäischen Ländern heute viele
Menschen die Arbeit nieder und
demonstrierten für höhere Löhne in
Belgien war vor allem der Verkehrssektor
betroffen am Brüsseler Flughafen
saventem fielen 60 Prozent der
Verbindungen aus und auch in
Griechenland stand das öffentliche Leben
still vor dem Parlament warfen einige
demonstrierende Molotow-Cocktails die
Polizei antwortete mit Tränengas
die Kölner Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt
gegen Kardinal Woelki untersucht wird
der Vorwurf der falschen
eidesstattlichen Versicherung es geht um
die Frage wann wusste Woelki dass dem
langjährigen Präsidenten der Sternsinger
Pilz sexualisierte Gewalt vorgeworfen
wird eine ehemalige Mitarbeiterin
erklärte dass sie Woelki bereits 2015
informiert habe wird selbst hatte
versichert er sei erste Mitte dieses
Jahres damit befasst worden die neuen
Vorwürfe wie es er zurück
heute ist 9 November kein anderes Datum
in Deutschland ist historisch so
aufgeladen
in der Pogromnacht am 9 November 1938
brennen Synagogen Nazis plündern
Geschäfte jüdische Menschen werden
misshandelt willkürlich verhaftet und
ermordet
am 9 November 1989 fällt die Berliner
Mauer es ist der Anfang vom Ende der
deutschen Teilung
friedlicher Aufbruch und entsetzliche
Verbrechen wie lässt sich beim
angemessen gedenken Dritter Buchholz
erinnern gegen das Vergessen wie in
vielen deutschen Städten erinnern sie
auch in Chemnitz einem beispiellosen
Verbrechen die Reichspogromnacht am 9
November 1938 wurden über 1.400
Synagogen und jüdische Einrichtungen
zerstört Menschen getötet von nun an
verfolgte das Naziregime
judensystematisch der Bundespräsident
sucht derweil nach neuen Formen diesem
Gedenktag gerecht zu werden an der Art
und Weise wie wir Deutsche unseren 9
November oder unsere verschiedenen 9
November in Erinnerung halten wie wir
Ihre würdig und angemessen gedenken
entscheidet sich unsere Identität der 9
November ist auch der Tag des Mauerfalls
ein Tag der Freude wie wird Deutschland
beiden Ereignissen gerecht der Präsident
des Zentralrats der Juden warnt vor dem
Verblassen der Erinnerung
am 9 November gibt es beeindruckende
ikonische Bilder vom Sturz der Mauer
voller Zuversicht Hoffnung und Farbe
sie dürfen aber die Bilder der
brennenden Synagogen voller Verzweiflung
Trauer und dunklen Schatten nicht
überlagern und was lernt Deutschland
daraus im Bundestag debattieren Sie wie
sich Antisemitismus bekämpfen lässt
tagtäglich gibt es mehrere Vorfälle ich
schäme mich dafür dass in diesem Land
jüdische Kindertagesstätten und Schulen
noch immer polizeilich bewacht werden
müssen müssen alles dafür tun dass das
nicht mehr nötig ist meine Damen und
Herren in Berlin gedenken sie auch der
Menschen die an der Mauer getötet wurden
ein Tag der für Deutschland ein
Schicksalstag ist die Erinnerung daran
ist auch eine Mahnung
und während der Veranstaltung heute
Mittag im Schloss Bellevue ist
tragischerweise der frühere DDR
Bürgerrechtler und langjährige grünen
Abgeordnete Werner Schulz
zusammengebrochen und gestorben wenn er
Schulz war ein Mensch der sich aus
vollem Herzen und mit großer Kraft sein
Leben lang für die Demokratie und die
Freiheit einsetzte schrieb
Bundespräsident Steinmeier an die Witwe
ein Nachruf von Christa Läpple
Schloss Bellevue es geht um den 9
November diesen geschichtsträchtigen Tag
der deutschen plötzlich mitten in der
Rede von Bundespräsident Steinmeier
verlässt Josef Schuster den Saal der
Arzt und zentralratsvorsitzende der
Juden versucht den zusammengebrochenen
grünen Politiker Werner Schulz zu retten
vergeblich
die Veranstaltung wird beendet zu
trauern ist und Werner Schulz 72 Jahre
ein Ostdeutscher der sich stets
einmischte ein unbeugsamer Streiter für
Demokratie unabhängig und gerne auch
unbequem für ihn war der 9 November ein
Glücksfall
meine Generation hat aus eigener Kraft
diese Demokratie errungen das ist eine
unglaublich hoher Wert den wir
eingebracht haben wir hätten ja noch
eine Menge zu tun gehabt in der DDR aus
war ja nicht so dass alles aufgeräumt
wurde gegen den Strom zu schwimmen das
war das Motto von Werner Schulz der
gebürtige Sachse studierte er
Lebensmittelchemie schloss sich aber
bald Oppositionsgruppen an er war
Mitbegründer des neuen Forum und
Mitglied der Grünen bis zuletzt trotz
aller Ärgernisse
neben allem Schrecken der mich erfasst
hat als ich von dem Tod hörte ist mir
bewusst geworden ohne Menschen wie ihn
hätten wir den 9 November 1989 überhaupt
nicht erlebt er war fähig seinen Ängsten
den Abschied zu geben und Mut an den Tag
zu legen Mut zur echten Demokratie sie
ist möglich das war die Welt von Werner
Schulz gestorben am 9 November 2022
zum Krieg in der Ukraine da kommt heute
diese Nachricht Russland zieht seine
Truppen aus einem Teil der strategisch
wichtigen Region casson zurück
moskausverteidigungsminister Scholl GU
gab dazu den Befehl gefilmt vom
russischen Staatsfernsehen in der
Südukraine sollen sich die Truppen
demnach aus der Stadt cashorn und aus
dem Gebiet westlich des Flusses Danny
pro zurückziehen russland hatte die
Region nach Kriegsbeginn besetzt und im
September
völkerrechtswidrig annektiert
und eigentlich wollten wir an dieser
Stelle noch zu unserem Korrespondenten
nördlich von tresonne in der Ukraine
schalten aber wegen technischen
Problemen ist das leider nicht möglich
kommen wir jetzt zum Sport zum Fußball
Norbert da läuft es für die Bayern ja
gerade sehr gut ja das kann man wohl
sagen 9 Pflichtspielsiege in Folge auch
gestern Abend ließ der FCB beim
Bundesliga Heimspiel gegen Bremen nichts
anbrennen sechs zu eins hieß es am Ende
für den Tabellenführer und das war sowas
von verdient
Torlaune bei Bayerns Nationalspielern
kurz vor der WM Jamal musiala besorgt
die frühe Führung der Bremer Ausgleich
kurz darauf hält nicht lange obwohl die
Bayern einen Elfmeter verschießen bevor
eine halbe Stunde rum ist hat Serge
gnabry in Zusammenarbeit mit Leon
Goretzka innerhalb von sechs Minuten auf
4:1 erhöht dabei trifft nabri nach
Vorarbeit von Leroy sané ein zweites Mal
und dann noch einmal gegen Ende der
Partie drei Tore in einem Spiel das war
ihm in der Bundesliga bis dahin erst
zweimal gelungen freut mich auch für den
DFB ich glaube es ist auch ein wichtiger
Spieler für Hansi und ja ich hoffe dass
er diesen flow in dem wir gerade ist
auch mitnehmen kann in das Spielen auf
Schalke und natürlich dann auch zu
werden den 61n Stand markierte 17 Jahre
alte Franzose Matthies tell sein
Vereinskamerad sadio mané verletzt sich
in der ersten Hälfte der Nationalspieler
Senegals droht für die WM auszufallen
Bayern Verfolger Dortmund dagegen mit
einer Schlappe in Wolfsburg der VfL
knüpfte nahtlos an seiner Erfolgsserie
an acht Pflichtspiele in Folge ohne
Niederlage 2:0 gegen die Borussia der
BVB jetzt schon sechs Punkte hinter
München
dortmund-coach konnte noch so toben an
der Seitenlinie der BVB brachte von 20
Torchancen keine ins Ziel bereits in der
sechsten Minute allerdings kassierte der
Tabellen vierte das erste Wolfsburger
Gegentor Micky van de Fan trifft nach
einem Eckball zum 1 zu 0 für Wolfsburg
der Anfangsphase das ist jetzt
wiederholt gewesen das ist etwas was wir
dringend abstellen müssen die Effizienz
hat heute gefehlt ja das stimmt auch
aber hinterher auch ein bisschen die
Klarheit gefehlt in der Nachspielzeit
macht Lukas Matcha dann den 2:0 Endstand
für Wolfsburg klar verletzt sich aber
und fällt für die WM definitiv aus der
Wermutstropfen für den derzeit
erfolgreichen VfL
tja fällt also auch aus morgen übrigens
die Bekanntgabe des WM-Kaders live zu
sehen bei uns ab 12 Uhr bei heute.de und
in der ZDF heute App Dankeschön schauen
wir noch welche Lottozahlen heute
gezogen worden die Gewinnzahlen lauten 2
16 29 32 47 49 Superzahl ist die 5
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
ruhiges Novemberwetter steht in den
nächsten Tagen an eher zu mild für die
Jahreszeit mehr gleich von Katja
horneffer
angesichts der wichtigen Zwischenwahlen
in den USA sendet das heute journal
heute aus Washington um 21 Uhr 45 mit
Marietta Slomka nach und nach kommen ja
die Ergebnisse aus dem Bundesstaaten
rein mehr dazu jetzt auch in einem
Spezial direkt nach dieser Sendung
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend die Kaltfront von tief
philomena zog heute allmählich weiter
ostwärts den äußersten Südosten Bayerns
zum Beispiel das Berchtesgadener Land
hat sie noch gar nicht erreicht dafür
setzt hier im Schwarzwald neuer
kräftiger Regen ein und auch über der
Nordseeküste gibt es kräftige shower die
können sogar mal mit Gewittern verbunden
sein und die breiten sich dann bis nach
Schleswig-Holstein in der Nacht aus am
kräftigsten regnen in der Nacht wird es
hier im Alpenvorland aber auch zwischen
dem Erzgebirge und dem Schwarzwald
regnet es noch sonst bleibt es trocken
und zum Teil ist es auch klar während
der Mosel oder auch in der Eifel und da
wird es dann auch am kühlsten da sinken
die Werte auf 5 Grad sonst liegen die
Tiefsttemperaturen bei 10 bis 6 Grad und
morgen liegen die Höchsttemperaturen
ganz ähnlich wie heute zwischen 11 Grad
zum Beispiel am Alpenrand und 16 Grad am
Niederrhein morgen Vormittag kann es am
Alpenrand noch etwas regnen das lässt
dann aber spätestens am Nachmittag nach
und ihre Wolken ziehen morgen hier über
den Norden Deutschlands auch vor allen
Dingen am Vormittag da wird es dann
nachmittags auch etwas freundlich der
Wind weht spürbar eigentlich nur aus der
Küste das ist ein West Südwestwind
danach geht es ruhiger weiter mal mit
Nebel oder hochnehmen und in jedem Fall
bei 7 bis 17 Grad wir sehen uns